BREAKING NEWS.
NEWLY RELEASED B VIDEO
SHOWS TPE OF
ANDRADWING A
EDUIEV U ABO
DIST
>> Reporter: IEALLY IS DISTURBI,
THIS A ST LET M
YOU BACK TO AFTERNOON
ABOUT 4 P.M. W B
PAAIDING T POSSIBLYM MSDED HIMSE
THEIR HOME WITHULPL
WEAPONS.
SHE THOUGHT H HAD HIMSEL OUT
SHE HAD LEFT HER CELL PHONE AT
TH
USEDHAWOMAN'S PHONED
TOLD THAT HUSBAND
THE POLICE CAME.
THEY LKI DID FIND THAT
PARSCALE WAS ALIVE. M  HIM.
OK ON T TELEPHONE. TOIM OUTSIDE.
TRIED WITH HIM.
THEY GETEDRIVEWAY AALE
SE S BODY CAM
FOOTAGE.NEE
MINUTESTA
HAVE A SMALL CLIP SO YOU CE HO
>> HE WAS ACTIN CRAZY SO I AND .
OPEN THE BLINDSN TH
HEEN WHAASGUNSHOT.P
I'M ANYTHING, RELAX.
>>HE STARTED SAYG ALL[ ON THE
MAN.
GET ON THEGROUND,
>> G LICE.
>> I DIDN'T DOAN DO ANYT.
I DIDN'T DAN
>> STAY DOWN.
>> PUTIN
BACK.
>> WE'LL ALL OU DIDN'T DN'T
>> GET Y THE G INECOND, OKAY?REE
AGAIN, WE DON'T KNO
HAPPENN BSE
S BECAUSE THAT  ITED,
O I
ACCORDING  T POLICEEP IREARMS
INCLING HANDGUNSRIFLES
NOAH CORNG THAT HIS WIFOL
THAT HE WAS MAKING SUICIDAL
COMMENTS ALL
HE AND SHINK FROM ASWELL.
HOULDOTHERE'S A
WOMAN THAT THEIF MET UPHEEE WSE
USED NOTICED
ONAR ASKED HERUT ON T
911 CAHA RELEASED BUT
HERR IS REDACTET THAT WAS RELT.T
THE BRUISING ARM AND STOLD POLI
FEW DAYS AGO DURINGRCATION WITH
AND THATOT REPORT IT.
AS MENTIONED, JI H IN
THETAL.
HE'S BEIRE UNDERHE
BAR ALO ALLOWS THEM TO
INVOLUPORARILY CT
EM I THINK THEY MIGHT BEAR TSEL
GETTING TREATED
HE WASS PAST SUMMER
AS CAMPAIGN
ADVISORY POSITION
BUTNICATIONAGER
FOR THEPAIGN
PARSCALE IUR
HIM. ARE